why good morning you sexy beast would
you like me to make you some breakfast
oh I'm sorry I was having flashback
there folks this is Tim Ferriss this is
an addendum an urgent update recorded
after this episode was completed because
I was going through a roster of all the
most amazing things I've been able to
experience in my life and at the top of
the list was floating at zero gravity
experiencing weightlessness in a shuttle
and being able to say chase after
globules of water floating in mid-air or
chase skittles that you've tossed into
the air it's floating right in front of
your face say 5 feet away or screwing
around all the way around the perimeter
of the shuttle like a hamster in a
hamster wheel if you were inverted in a
way it's really amazing and I loved it
so much that I decided to give away a
flame so I am giving away a flight at
zero gravity and you can get it there's
no cost involved but it's only possible
this week that is the week of Monday
April 20th so jump on this right now I
would suggest that you pause this and
check it out just go to 4 hour work week
comm forward slash zero that's four hour
work week all spelled out fo you Rho you
are it cetera forward slash zero zer oh
let's check it out and now back to your
regular programming
this episode is brought to you by listen
headphones which are gorgeous and
produce incredible incredible incredible
at this altitude
this episode is brought to you by listen
headphones listen headphones are
gorgeous made out of real exotic
reclaimed wood but they are also doing
good in the world proceeds from each
purchase helps someone to hear for the
first time through the Starkey Hearing
Foundation I've been using listen
headphones since they came out partially
because the founders started the company
after reading the 4-hour workweek and
now they're available in Nordstrom and
all over the place
they're super high quality and if you
want to see the headphones that I travel
with that I love both in ear and out of
ear so kind of big all old-school
headphones then you can go to listen
headphones calm forward-slash Tim that's
LS TN headphones calm forward slash Tim
you will also get a $50 that's right $50
discount that's a big whopping 5-0 folks
so go to listen headphones calm forward
slash Tim LST n headphones calm forward
slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
99designs which is your one-stop shop
for all things graphic design related
they have thousands upon thousands of
designers around the world you put up
what you want whether that's a business
card a t-shirt a website and app
thumbnail whatever and they submit
drafts mock-ups and designs that you can
choose from and you get an original
design you love or your money back
I have used them for years including to
grab cover concepts for the 4-hour body
which went on to become number one New
York Times and it really was a
springboard for everything so go to
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim and
you can also get two things a $99
upgrade and just for the month of April
just for you guys you can get an
additional $30 off and that is total
savings of 129
so check out 99designs dot-com forward
slash Tim well hello ladies and
gentlemen this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show I am drinking tea with
coconut oil in it because I am in
ketosis so my brain is running like
speedy Gonzalez on some type of
biochemical advantage but that's not
what I'm here to talk about I am here to
do what I do every episode and that is
deconstruct world-class performers to
find the tools tricks routines habits
and so on that you can use whether those
people are billionaire investors like
for instance Peter Thiel it was the
first money into Facebook also
co-founder of PayPal and Palantir or
celebrities and actors like Arnold
Schwarzenegger tech icons like Matt
Mullenweg behind a wordpress
wordpress.com and so on and so forth
musicians we've got everybody and I've
wanted to interview a professional
wrestler for a very long time now after
seeing the movie the wrestler but also
having wrestled myself and having
watched WWE WWF before that and then the
the rise of MMA and I managed to get a
hold of a fantastic fantastic performer
and incredible athlete Triple H so
Triple H who is a 13-time world champion
in the W
but that is not all he's also the
executive vice president of talent live
events and creative at the WWE and we
talked about just about everything in
this episode his real name is Paul
Levesque and we dig into the questions
of misconceptions related to both Triple
H his his stage name a stage persona and
WWE the important lessons he learned
while training with a wrestler named
killer Kowalski including getting hit in
the back of the head with a phone book
in a garbage bag
ouch and we get into his a longevity how
he avoids and also repairs injuries
pregame rituals including input from a
trainer named Joe DeFranco of course his
colleague in arms the Undertaker and
even Floyd Mayweather and who does he
model how does he view parenting he has
a bunch of daughters and it goes on and
on we really dig deep it it turned out
better than I could have expected and I
expected it to be good so I hope you
really enjoy this of course all show
notes can be found at 4-hour workweek
comm forward slash podcast all spelled
out and please enjoy my conversation
with the one and only
Triple H Paul Levesque
Paul welcome to the show thank you very
much man it's an honor to be here I am
so excited for this you are a massive
human being makes a job requirement this
you to be a job requirement and the IE
you have worn a lot of hats and I've had
a lot of different titles a lot of
different jobs when someone asks you
what do you do if they don't recognize
you how do you answer that question you
got it's funny now because I'm kind of
been that this weird kind of combo
Twilight Zone of the last bits of my my
in-ring wrestling career you know even
then when I did that I used to say I was
an entertainer and because if people
it's our the deputy W is a weird thing
like like it's like one of those things
like if you if you not into it no
explanation can explain it to you to
make you like it and then you are into
it there's no explanation necessary you
know it just is what it is and so to say
sometimes say oh WWE like they would go
like oh yeah you know and it just had a
weird connotation to it when you say
entertainer Oh what kind oh you know WWE
it just took on a different meaning sure
to people that don't understand what we
do so I always went with that right now
it's it's kind of a combo you know we
have a saying that we use at WWE which
is our job is put smiles on people's
faces and it's kind of the overall thing
of what we do but it's been 90 percent
of my day as an executive so there you
go okay we're gonna also we're gonna dig
into that and rewind the clock and so
look at the trajectory but what are
misconceptions that people have about
you or Triple H or at WWE I think they
don't you know they just see what they
see on TV they see you know
the misconception for me is that I'm
very much what you see on television or
I'm that I'm this character or they see
the simplistic things of what we do you
know it's funny even if you're this huge
fan of the WWE they get so upset over
things like well good why would this guy
beat that guy just
you know it's one of the terms right now
let's bury them you know it's um it's a
show and what they don't get about our
show is we are like this never-ending if
you can compare it to what ever you want
comic books soap opera TV drama movie
but it never ends there's always another
chapter and they get so upset in the
moment of not knowing that you know not
liking maybe the end of the chapter that
they're on there's another chapter it
starts tomorrow it actually started
right now when this one ended you know
and they don't get that and they can't
wait for that and they don't understand
all the complexities that goes on you
know go on behind the scenes so it's
that's probably the biggest
misconception is that we're just you
know that the W is just a bunch of guys
at its simplest form that just go to the
ring in their underwear and pretend to
fight with each other you know but when
you really break it down it's it's a
massive global business oh there's a lot
behind it oh I've been so impressed by
it for so so long not the least of which
and and we'll certainly explore the the
physical and mental stamina how many
matches would you say you have had total
Wow to date televised or otherwise
thousands you know if if you break it
down simplistically in math is not my
strong suit so but you know I started
wrestling I think in like 93 ish just
just training 92 93 training was this in
New Hampshire or yeah in New Hampshire I
went to I train with a guy named killer
Kowalski and old who my mom loves by the
way oh really yeah I wanted to dig into
that yeah he was a you know one of the
first guys to become kind of like
globally known and I started training
with him yet I can't a school if you
want to call it that I was a little
rundown mill building with a boxing ring
in it and in Malden Massachusetts and I
started training over there so if you
break it down from there
to today of 20-plus years and then one
you know once I made it to the WWE which
was 95 even if you just want to look at
it from there and just say 20 years 20
years I probably for a lot of those
years wrestled
250 280 days a year sometimes in the
weekends we did double shots so we'd
wrestle on matinee in the afternoon and
then a night show so it's a lot a lot of
mileage yeah that's a lot of eyelid yeah
what were the things we always say it's
not the years it's the miles but
figuratively and literally and and it's
a hell of a lot of travel but before I
get to asking about travel on all these
different training aspects what were the
most important lessons you learned while
training with killer Kowalski it's funny
a lot of the things I think as in life
he taught me a lot of things that I
didn't know he was teaching me at the
time he would tell me a lot of things
that I would like oh she's just like mr.
Miyagi approach yeah yeah you know you
had this it was a very would've worked
very well in today's millennial age but
like he had that his theory of telling
you did something wrong was hitting you
in the back of the head with a phone
book that was in like a shopping bag you
know oh my god and but yeah he would
just teach all the he wouldn't say a
whole lot and then all of a sudden he'd
come in and he would say you know it
needs it you need to be spectacular make
everybody look at you no one else and
then he would just walk away and then
you really what does that mean like I
don't you know what I mean you kind of
had to figure it out now there's a lot
of things that he said to me then that I
find myself telling the young guys now
in a different way but it's the same
lessons kind of you know are there any
examples that come to mind well just
just and how to be spectacular but also
how to break things down and to just
look at what you do like never be never
be satisfied with what you do if you
don't do something well don't do it
unless you want to spend the time to
improve that like it's still to this day
I see a lot of guys do stuff in the ring
that I'm like he doesn't do that well
because it all the time it just you know
you shouldn't do that I have things that
I don't do well in the ring just don't
let's just what would be up for example
there's just one thing that guys take
were they
they go through the top men middle
turnbuckle and hit the post right right
from the inside and hit it with their
shoulder I just it's one of those mental
block things for me like I can't I just
like can't seem to navigate going
between the two turnbuckles and getting
the thing like I always get stuck
somehow or I've tried to do it before
and it's just one of those things like
doesn't work out well for me so I never
do it and if guys will grab me in the
ring over the years and say like take
the post and I just know because I don't
mid flight correction I just don't do
that well I'm not gonna do it and I
think there's little things like that
that guys don't analyze what they do
they they do what they do and then they
go and they say oh that was really good
in the overall picture of things right
it was really good people really liked
it it was but there was some things in
that that weren't really good so the it
averaged out well but there are things
they should have emitted yeah you know
and to me I don't know I've always been
the kind of guy if you're if you're
doing it why why wasn't everything what
you wanted it to be in there they
shouldn't be wasted movement there
shouldn't be things that aren't what you
want them to be I don't want to do
something just to get to the next thing
you know no idea and what are you
particularly good at in that in that
environment what are the things that you
the strengths that you focused on for me
it was never about he was never about
individual moves and I think as the
business met maybe some guys now looking
at it and they they think differently
because they might look at my style and
say like I was never over the top
spectacular guy but I wasn't supposed to
be I was usually the bad guy so I wanted
to have that I want it to be that
constant and let the other guy be
spectacular around me and for me it was
never about the spectacular moves it was
about the drama of the the match and I
look at what we do is we're more like
rocky the movie then we are legitimate
you know like boxing right it's about
the story that you tell so if the story
is really good going in and you care
about the two characters and then you
make that emotional story play out
through those
characters non-verbally in the ring
that's the magic of what we do it
doesn't matter if you know yeah it makes
the highlight reel like oh my god he did
this one spectacular move was crazy I
don't know how he he made it through
that or whatever it's it's not really
about that because tomorrow they'll be
another guy can do that move better than
you just did it right and it'll be even
more spectacular he'll come up with
another way to do it that's even crazier
well you mentioned rocker and it's it's
it's it's about the story arc not just a
handful of really good lines of dialogue
exactly yeah yeah and that's the thing
of it and you'll watch it's one of the
things that works we have the WWE
Network it's a lot of old content people
will go back and they'll watch
WrestleMania one you know over and over
again and how great it is and or
WrestleMania 3 and all these things it's
because it's an emotional story if it
was just about the moves it wouldn't be
so impactful to you still it the the
emotional story that's why people will
go back and watch the movie Rocky over
and over again because it's a great
story they very rarely go back and watch
you know there's exceptions Muhammad Ali
and and Foreman or something you know
moments in time but the average person
unless they were like a boxing
connoisseur doesn't go back and watch
boxing over and over again you know and
you know it's fascinating about the
examples you just gave like whether it's
Ali Frazier or whatever those were those
in real life ended up being like story
arcs because you would have this back
and forth in this drama and the Thrilla
in Manilla and there were all the
elements of sort of the the monomyth or
the yeah and well and and even when you
go back and usually watch those fights
you go back and you watch them in a show
that now chronicles the story of it ties
them together yeah yeah it chronicles
the story of those those epic contests
you know and and that's the the reality
of the story you know it's you know said
all the time if you know who's in the
ring fighting you'll tune in and your
watch to just watch two guys fight for
no apparent reason it's not that
interesting unless you're a connoisseur
of the of what they're doing if you're
watching the FC and your big makes
martial arts fan or all those thing
and there's a lot of those but they're
very into the the what's going on
scientifically and you know the chess
game the technical chess game that's
going on but that's not the general
public to hit the general public they
need to know something about the two
guys and why they're fighting right you
know the the fighting now at your peak
point in in your your onstage wrestling
career you mentioned two hundred and
something like 250 to 300 days of the
year you're probably traveling something
like that traveling yeah and what were
some of the keys to your longevity being
able to maintain that and I know we have
a common connection and Joe DeFranco and
he's mentioned that you very very rarely
if ever miss training days and then
maybe you could speak to that but even
if that means coming in at 2:00 3:00 in
the morning to train what are it what
have been some of the keys or practices
that have allowed you to sustain that
type of torturous schedule um I think
you know you speak a lot in your in your
podcasts and your books and everything
about routines and having things that
you do and I'm very big in that way and
I like I like to have my life kind of up
when it when it gets chaotic it bothers
me and it's it sounds silly because like
what we do is chaotic at all times like
my day varies in you know people talk
about when you do live TV like Monday
Night Raw for us we work on that show
and editing done and like sometimes guys
are walking up the curtain somebody's
shouting a change to them as they're
walking through the curtain you know
it's so the chaos is there but having
that consistent thing so for me I had
very distinct things like if I was yet
in the beginning there wasn't as much
supplements and and it was a little bit
more difficult but as supplements became
more available I would I'm like big on
the preparation part so like if I was
gonna get on a plane to fly to Japan I
would take either containers or or later
when they were there that the I would
make my own protein shakes right I'd
the two scoops of protein and the thing
I'd put some oil in there for whatever I
needed I'd put the top on it no liquid
in there and I'd stick it inside my
carry-on bag so and I would time it in
my head so I'm on the flight for it's a
16-hour flight I've got three hour I
need to eat every three hours I'm not
gonna count on the food on the plane
that would just be bonus food so every
three hours I have a shake for every
three hours and then set my watch to go
off every three hours time to eat and
I'd get a shake out get water drink my
shake put it in and go back to sleep
write whatever I needed to do when I
landed I would check into the hotel
second we checked in I'd ask them to is
the gym open can I go train even if it
was to get on a bike and ride for 15
minutes reset that I learned early that
it seemed to me anytime I did that I
didn't get jet like any time I did that
I seemed to like we can kick he's
wrestling terms like I'd get kicked out
faster right so while everybody else
would be in the building dragon that day
I'd be like lemon I feel great like you
know I don't feel so bad getting your
blood flowing resetting your clock you
know if we were in Australia I would
always like that last day there I would
force myself to stay up because then I
could sleep the whole way home and by
the time I landed I was I'm landing in
the morning and it's perfect like I'm
just waking up and it's I'm great you
know I do the same thing I'll and I try
to find a gym whether it hotel something
ride a bike you set my clock do the deal
you know
so those routines and regimented stuff
and same with my training when new guys
would start a lot on the road like
internationally when we're all traveling
together it's hard when you go overseas
you're on a bus there there's a gym set
up for you but they don't know how like
how do I get to the gym I'm not sure my
specifically on stairs get on a bus I
don't know the guys would always come to
me and say hey look we've always heard
that you go to gym every day can I go
with you so yeah I'd meet downstairs
bunch of guys you come down we'd all go
to the gym together cuz I would go every
day I didn't like missing it I didn't
like you know it was to me was that
regimented thing and I can look back at
my career and say I think part of that
regimented stuff is why I was able to
maintain it
or maintain that schedule because I was
one of the guys also that really truly
believed in that when you make it the
job gets harder it's not the other way
around
you don't make it and then go can I can
Cruz because now I'm the guy and now
that means I can say no and I cannot do
these things I felt the opposite when
you get there now to your responsibility
to not say no so you know I I've had
times where I've worked 64 straight days
and just everybody else went home I went
on a media tour everybody else went back
home I went to something else I did that
for years you know and that that
regimented having those distinct
patterns so to speak I think helped help
keep that I think it helps preserve your
bandwidth also for making decisions
about other things so you don't have to
decide each morning or each day what all
the elements your teen are going to look
like yeah I heard you talk just recently
that's a new podcast and my research
with it because I've read you your books
and but I'm hearing somebody speak is
different than what you put in your mind
of how they speak correctly so I want to
feel like God that guy sounds a lot
dumber but you know you put something in
your head and then get there go so I
signed a more like Barry Manilow yes you
you spoke that was bad interview
etiquette on my phone oh yeah we're
talking about resilience it's bad memory
on my part is routine oh I know what
does he say yeah I believe that like
training is almost like a meditation
right I totally agree
Anthony Robbins say he doesn't didn't
meditate he's in like shutting off easy
opposite he wants to just keep going but
I also believe you need to reboot your
brains your brain will get stuck in like
it's like when you go to sleep and you
can't stop thinking about something you
got going on at work and you can't get
it out and in the morning you realize
like it was actually gibberish that was
I think training when you do it well if
you're into it like you can't focus you
can't be
in the middle of trying to do a heavy
set of something and be thinking about
another project you have to be in that
moment and it allows you reboot which I
kind of believe is what meditation and
all that stuff is anyways it's just a
reset button for a second that just
allows you to go like okay start over
clean the plate and now let's do this
again you know and that's really to me
what training is definitely digging a
little bit more on the routines for
instance and in the last let's just say
as you've gotten older in the last
handful of years how do you what is your
pregame ritual if you have one before
you're gonna go out and compete well and
perform yeah that's well that just
became a necessity of of age of I never
and just for people listening if you
don't mind me asking how how old either
45 but so you know for years when I was
doing all that stuff with wrestling you
know wrestling all those dates and
everything it's funny because some of
the younger guys would would joke with
me about it like you're like the old
school guy like I would literally be
sitting in the chair up at we called
korilla position right before you walk
out the curtain named after an old
wrestle a gorilla monsoon but I would
just be sitting in a chair my music
idiot but get up and go to the ring and
like they would say you don't warm-up a
toss I'll walk to the ring it's good to
be a good warm-up you know I'll start
slow it'll be fine now I have to like
stretch and warm up and Joe DeFranco you
mentioned my strength and conditioning
guys one of the things when I'm really
bad with years and dates but four years
ago as my career was kind of winding
down and I was but I was I was still
wrestling fairly regularly and I I had
had this problem I thought it was a neck
injury and really having all this
problem with my neck in my shoulder and
I got into a position with a company
where I needed to go make a couple of
movies for them long story but I went to
go make two movies I ended up taking
about a month off from the ring to go
make these two movies and was supposed
to come back while I was making the
movies one day I went to the gym to
Train and it had gotten to a point where
I couldn't raise my left arm up like
over my shoulder and my
neck was really bad and I've been going
to see our team physician you know the
guy who runs our medical and I've been
you know getting stuck with needles and
dye and MRIs and things and they kept
saying like it looks great we don't see
there's clearly something nerve going on
here but we don't know what it is and
they kept doing all this stuff and when
the gym one day and tore my bicep and it
didn't hurt at all it like snap I looked
down I had the big gap in my arm and I
was just mad morning I was like oh he
just rolled up like a phoenician blow it
toward the top so it just calmed down
and made like this divot there right and
I heard I had headphones on I heard it
and I looked down there was a divot I
was like son of a [ __ ] I can't believe
it tore my bicep so I'm like mad I put
my weights down and like literally I was
done training I was just gonna do like a
couple extra sets of biceps work and I
called the guy to come back and get me
and as I went to go outside like I was
sweating and I'm pissed so I'm just
gonna leave and I go to put my switching
on and as I did I put my sweatshirt like
through my arm up over my head to put my
switching on and realize like wait a
minute like I can move my my arm all the
way around my head like that I couldn't
do that shoulder mobility yeah that was
like my everything came back and hey
wait my neck doesn't hurt it was all
from like this bicep and I had to get
surgery and the whole thing and it but
it got me to a point in my head like I'm
getting older I'm falling apart a little
bit like I have to start maybe I should
think about trying to train like an
athlete instead of just like going to
the being a bodybuilder and just looking
good or whatever so I'm not like a guy
that just like called a local gym like I
have to then like dig into it so I start
like researching trainers and everything
and ironically I end up probably where
you did in your quest to do when you did
for our body which is you start
researching all these guys that become
the best at what they do and I I come
across Joe DeFranco it keeps coming back
up Joe DeFranco
so then I called Joe DeFranco out of the
blue one day and just say you know hey I
was I was actually because he was in
Jersey and I was in Connecticut I was
thinking maybe he could wreck
men to me to somebody and he said can I
come and meet with you I'd like to meet
with you and just so I can analyze the
thing I still have my arm in a sling and
everything and just finished making the
movies I didn't have the surgery until
after I finished making the movies and
he came and said after we met he's like
you seem like a really great guy I'd
like to take a stab at doing this with
you I'll Drive up here I'm willing to do
it drive up and there's the thing he's
awesome he's a great guy
and for people who aren't familiar he's
very well known for a lot of reasons but
does a lot of work with football
athletes training for that I fell
combine yeah and that's how he ended up
the chapters in the 4-hour body where I
showed how unathletic I am but how much
Joe could improve my performance
attempting to simulate the compound for
a handful of chapters but please
continue I just want to give some
context for people yeah great guy
yeah and just wealth of knowledge
incredibly smart and he said to me so
this will be a difficult transition for
you because your mindset is totally
different you know I'd never been with a
strength and conditioning guy everything
I learned in the gym was from
bodybuilders or power lifters I just I
just went to the gym and trained with
guys and learned everything I could but
I was a sponge forward you know Arnold
was my hero and you know I like just was
a sponge for all that stuff and but
that's how I learned it so strength and
conditioning and the whole stretching
and mobility was totally foreign to me
and he said this is gonna be a tough
thing for you we'll see you can do it
cuz tough with old dogs new tricks and I
just want him and I said dude I will
tell you this I am I'm all-in
tell me what to do I'll go do it but it
changed my life changed my life
athletically I went from a guy with you
know gimping going upstairs because my
knees were killing me I've torn both my
quads and my knees were really bad and
all that I had zero knee pain now as
strong as I've ever been I don't have
physical issues but it's because of that
type of training and Joe and you know he
was the one of the guys that got me like
when you do wrestle here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna get you in this
kind of shape and then
you're gonna here's gonna be your
pre-match ritual of you know your
stretching in your mobility we're gonna
light your body up get your nerves
kicking and fire in and then you're
gonna go you know and that's what I
dunno and it works out a whole lot
better whatever
what are as opposed to going from the
gorilla position straight out to the to
the ring
what are and I can prep what I'll
provide for folks obviously lots of
links to everything that you're up to
but also I'll ping Joe and get some
links to exercises and yeah and some
videos what what does that look like now
what are some of the exercises or the
sequence it's um it's a lot of mobility
stuff Kasich squats you know is that a
we did Kasich squatter's no no Hill well
it depends but usually I don't like if
I'm getting ready to go for a match but
like he'll have me do Kasich squats into
maybe just like a squat but when I come
down I'm pushing my knees out to the
side to stretch my groin out into some
type of like eccentric explosive push-up
but just getting things to fire my
nervous system wake my nervous system up
but then also just open my joints up a
little bit and just warm my body up but
it's never anything like I see guys
running down always it's doing all these
things to get a sweat going I'm never at
that point but when I'm done it I always
feel like alive you know as opposed to
just kind of physically shut down but
mentally aware because I'm about to go
to the ring so you know no matter how
many years you've been doing this you're
still like nervous and like freaking out
and to then have your body just kick in
and wake up hoping you there you know
what I mean and that's really what it is
but it's it's just a he buries it but
it's a little series of exercise it just
makes me go how long does it typically
take 5-10 minutes oh it's nice lessons
not short sweet yeah it's it's not you
know I just go white right from one
thing to the other it's it's awesome
good little deal I'll fall pingyao so
people you can you can find that at the
show notes at for our blog com
the fear factor what you guys do is it
can be very dangerous I mean there are
risks involved or when you're when
you're nervous
or have been nervous what is your inner
dialogue sound like when you're
preparing yourself to go out when you've
been most nervous what are you saying to
yourself hmm so it's changed over the
years I used to get really intense and
really like almost like that same level
of intensity if you were gonna go for a
personal record squat or something where
you know you just get in that zone of
intensity and just nothing else's around
you and you're in your own little world
and just on fire ready to tear through
this thing and that when I was younger
that used to be the thing for me now
it's much more of an inner dialogue of
you have been doing this for 20 years
you know how to do this like relax and
this is fun
like and they're in somewhere there's
that inner dialogue in me saying it
could be the last time you do this enjoy
it you know what I mean like Undertaker
and I had a conversation a couple of
years ago about this like you it's it's
a little bit of like you can still do
this like in calming yourself down but
at the same point I'm like don't forget
to enjoy this moment like when you're
out there because you might not get
another one you don't know you know and
and injuries do happen especially as you
get older so and you can't think about
it once you're out there and that's the
thing for me it's always been this
emotion and nerve and thus my music hits
and the second I walk out it's gone like
I don't have any of it when I'm in the
ring waiting for the other guy or
whatever I don't have any of it and it's
an interesting thing to me that I'm
friends with Floyd Mayweather an
incredible athlete yeah and I was
walking him to the ring one time in qez
and we got there early and his guys came
and got me and I wanted to watch some of
the undercard and then they came and got
me and they said you know floored just
want to say hi before he starts getting
ready and stuff chatted for a few
minutes so I came we Steph and I went
backstage my wife
and we get in his locker room he's
laying down the couch watching
basketball game and we come in and say
hello and all that he's okay see you
know now we're talking a little bit but
I'm trying to be ultra respectful of him
he's about to go and you know it's just
massive fight and so I ii there's like a
lull in the conversation like hi man
we're gonna get out of your hair and and
i head back and we'll come back here
when it's time for us to get ready for
your deal and he's like man you know got
to take off you said now i'm enjoying
the conversation have funny and he's
like completely relaxed and i said so
another low on the conversation i go
we're gonna run for it i don't want to
be in your way
and he goes on her i'm telling you i'm
just chillin watching the game and I
said you're not wound up about this at
all and he goes why would I be wound up
I'm either ready or I'm not worrying
about it right now I get a change gonna
happen it's gonna happen I've either
done everything I can to be ready for
this or I'm not that's a fair point i
sat back down just is very calm and
relaxed amazing I think when you feel in
your mind that you're ready you're ready
and you're gonna have those nerves but
it's you know it's there when when you
were coming up let's just say when you
when you would hit your stride somewhat
so you're starting to make the ascent
through the ranks and really become
popular when you thought of the word
successful who was the person in your
head at that time um I don't know it's
hard to say because I looked at an
inside of the inside of our business
there were guys like for me you know my
favorite performer character was Ric
Flair just kind of felt like overall he
had the best package of everything to
offer you know there were guys that were
great show men very popular or guys that
were great at one thing very poppy he
had the kind of the combo of great in
ring performer and made everybody look
good this great character all these
things in inside the wrestling business
that was the component of success
me just that level of performer the way
he handled himself in the ring I always
wanted to be the in ring kind of general
and understand and I it's one of the
things I prided myself on at the peak of
my career was I could tell you at any
given time if there were six people
involved in something I could tell you
at any given time if I close my eyes in
the ring where they all were like no
matter how much they were moving around
and what they were doing I knew where
they were I knew what they had in their
hands I knew like just on glimpses as I
was moving around the ring I always felt
like it was my job if something was
gonna screw up that was my fault it
wasn't because he didn't know what was
coming it was because I didn't control
that so I was failing to control was
mine to take because it was what I could
count on I couldn't rely on you know
this might get screwed up because maybe
there's a confusion between those two
guys over there it's supposed to do
their thing so I was took it on me to
make sure I was there to tell them this
is coming up be ready here we go get the
chair whatever you know Flair was very
good at that so that was like for me
from that point of view was a success
component but there was a lot of things
that I looked for a wrestling didn't
define me as far as what I saw was
successful I looked at and you know I
looked at my father-in-law now Vince I
looked at and that is a guy that saw
business that was one thing but had a
vision of it being something else he saw
this little territory business and
thought there should be one global brand
that everybody watches because the
world's getting smaller cable is taking
over and so he had this vision and then
he just kind of set out doing it I
looked at Arnold I remember you know as
a kid reading education of a body they
learn
very structured methodical set of here's
what I want to do here's what I want to
be and here's how I'm gonna get there
you know that those kind of things and
those kind of people were success models
for me Arnold was that in in the
structure you know I just said it to him
a few weeks ago like for me I say this
in interviews a lot the Jim taught me
everything I need to know out for life
you know I walked in a gym at 14 I fell
in love with it I fell in love with the
end result look right as I'm always in
awe of these big powerful impressive
guys I think as part of what I dug about
wrestling you know I enjoyed the
physical and all that stuff of it and
fell in love with that really holy
that's probably what led me to the gym
at first but but just the the discipline
of it and they're going to the gym when
I say it's like life the more you put in
the more you get out
the harder you work the better the
results you know if you're willing to
prepare to sacrifice in such just about
going the gym lifting weights and then
going on goofing off the rest of the
time it's your life so if you discipline
your diet if you discipline your rest if
you don't go to the party with your
friends if you don't do all these things
your results follow suit you know I I
just did I just got inducted into the
International Sports Hall of Fame
Arnold's International Sports Hall
congratulations thank you and but I
bring it up because Evander Holyfield
was there and he told this story and
I've never heard it said this way before
and I'm sorry Evander but I'm gonna
steal this he told me that you know he
was giving his speech and he said that
his coach at one point in time told him
very like his very first day said you
could be Muhammad you could be the next
mom and I late and he said do you want
to do that he said he had asked his mom
and then he went back home and he came
back and he said I want to do that and
he said okay is that a dream or a goal
this is a difference I've never heard it
said that way before but it struck to me
so much so that I've said it to my kid
now like is that a dream or goal because
a dream too
something you fantasize about that just
my pro will never happen probably the
goal is something you set a plan and
work towards and achieve set a dream or
a goal kind of always looked at my stuff
that way so the people that were
successful models to me were people that
had structured goals and then put a plan
in place to get to those things and I
think that's what impressed me about
Arnold Jordan press me about my father
want to this day he's still very much a
you know here's the goal there's I'm
gonna get there you know Energizer Bunny
that's amazing yeah and you guys are
seem like peas in a pod from us stamina
and endurance stem you know and you you
I've heard you say it before when when
you have that goal in mind now it's not
gonna do this thing to get that done
it's you you can't wait to do that thing
to get that done because it's gonna get
you closer to your goal right well since
the compass that allows you to find
order in the chaos - yeah yeah
the parent thing I don't I don't yet
have kids that I know of at some point I
would love to have a family how do you
think about being a father what type of
father do you want to be what do you
think is is important in that role
that's a tough one I have three girls at
three I'm an eight six and four very
well spaced yeah yeah and that's it yeah
but it's man it's it's hard but when the
pressure as a parent if you you know
hopefully if everybody takes his job
seriously you know there's you're giving
them the examples of how they're gonna
live their life kids don't do what you
say they they do what they see so how
you live your life is their example you
know I've heard it said and and I
believe this is like the way I treat
their mother and the way I treat them is
what they're gonna look for in a in a
significant other it's like you gotta
think so yeah like so what do I want
them to have in their life holy cow now
I got to do all that stuff it's a lot
you know
then you add in all the other things of
life it's a very it's a very difficult
challenge but you wanna you want to
teach him right from wrong you want to
teach them you want to give them a path
in a direction but at the same time you
know you learn as much from your
failures as you do for me successes so
you can't you can't give them everything
you want to help them so bad like I'm
watching you make a mistake and I want
to help you but go ahead and make the
mistake because you got to learn from
that mistake you know what I mean and
it's it's tough to do but you have to
and there's no manual that's the hard
thing about kids right there's no manual
that comes with it and you're just doing
the best you can I remember when we got
our first one home we did the boss
spittle they put it in the car seat and
you take the thing home and then we
walked in the door we put it on the step
that we're like what do we do now we
just stood there looking at her for a
little bit like what do we like what we
do
just like eventually it she cried and we
had a feeder and whatever you don't know
what to do you just like you don't we
have a kid oh yeah luckily I was I gotta
go on the road the the aspect of
routines that we touched on earlier
I'd love to to bring back into focus for
a second
specifically morning routines what is
what is the first 60 minutes of your day
look like and I'll probably ask a bunch
of really irritating nitpicky questions
because that's how I am
well what if what is what is when you
wake up what is the first sort of 60 to
90 days 60 to 90 minutes of your day
look like yeah so I wish I had a really
cool example of that like you know wake
up I got a cryogenic cryo chamber he's
like at this elaborate ritual of
mind-altering spiritual like jumping in
a hot tank in a cold taggin of mind
involves my kids waking me up in an
ungodly hour after I you know like we we
work under the premise of my wife and I
and to me
she hits us even more than I do cuz
she's got all the roles and all this
stuff and then she's mom and when you're
the dad it's it's um it's a big
responsibility but the mom like if
anything happens if they wake up they go
to her first you know when the kids wake
up in the middle of the night unless
they're scared they might call that if
they're scared but usually it's mom
because they just rounds more the
comforter right so it's it's all those
things so that's even harder job but you
know we train late at night we get home
we try to get home every night no matter
what to spend a little bit of time with
them and put them down and and you know
read my book whatever get them in bed so
Joe comes to my house around 10:00
o'clock
so buddy em yeah so I get them done you
know we get them in bed change and then
Joe's there and we start training and
usually but you know by the time you
warm up takes me a while to warm up I'm
10 o'clock at night yeah you trained and
do all the stuff by 10:00 we get done
usually just 1 o'clock you know in that
ballpark and then you know you you're
getting a bed after one o'clock they're
up at like 6:00 at the latest you know
and they're in the room so there's no
really cool ritual I wish I could say
gentlemen a cryo chamber it's usually me
stumbling down stairs with them to try
to make every morning my ritual is I am
also ironically out of your book Dave
Palumbo as jumbo palumbo yeah dave has
I've been friends with him for years and
he he's a big ketogenic diet guy so he
like works with my diet a lot when I'm
getting ready for a Wrestlemania so
Dave's kind of my diet guy uses protein
powder species protein but so every
morning roll downstairs 2 scoops of whey
protein a bunch of Starbucks coffee
powdered Starbucks coffee some macadamia
nut oil and I make a shake and that's
the start like that you've got to get
the cake in this powder it's Starbucks
macadamia nut oil what else was in there
2 scoops of ice lies protein nice and
some ice blend it all up it
Starbucks smoothie kind of concoction
but very healthy and has enough caffeine
in there to at least make me realize
what's going on get them ready for
school my wife and I get them ready for
school jump in the shower either
depending if I'm getting ready for like
WrestleMania it's either throat sweats
on because I'm gonna bring them to
school and then get a workout in because
usually I train twice a day when I'm
getting ready for Wrestlemania or
something but train and then off to work
if I'm not getting ready for
Wrestlemania its shower get ready suit
bring them to school you know we drive
them to their school get them to school
get them in their class do all the stuff
and then drive to the office start the
day get home at you know 7:30 8 o'clock
at night and repeat and this is all in
Connecticut they're all in Connecticut
and the the HQ is I want to system that
can get this wrong it's not Stanford is
it yeah yep okay right from 95 right off
the highway close to the UBS building
yeah down the street not far and used to
live I used to work there I guess I
thought the slip of the tongue lived
there is probably pretty honest living
in the office I what is your what is
your role currently at WWE in the UH in
the executive capacity so I am the
executive vice president of talent live
events and creative so if you look at
the core of what we do as a company like
from the the product itself raw
Smackdown all that and we're a lot more
than that because we have movies and
music and like it's I sell times like
saying Marvel is a comic book company
but but that's the core of what we do I
control those aspects so talent and that
goes from we have a department Tala
relations which is like their HR and
they handle everything that has to do
with talent from their travel to and
anything that has to do with them all
the logistics of WrestleMania week you
know what talent are doing there's a
thousand appearances for town literally
in the week of Wrestlemania they have to
handle all the logistics of getting who
where
making sure nobody's late and all of it
it's a maze
from - talent development which is the
biggest probably thing that's closest to
my art that I do which is where do we
find talent what are we recruit them
from where do we where do we where do we
recruit them from how do we train them
we opened a performance Center in
Orlando Florida to a developmental
territory or a developmental system that
I have called NXT that has become kind
of like an alternative brand through -
how do they then evolve and get into the
main roster of the WWE so basically what
we did is kind of created college
football to get guys ready for the NFL
and then the last part of what I do is
is creative which Vince is kind of the
ultimate filter of creative I'm more
while I weigh in a lot on that stuff and
the content that's gonna go on the
network and all these things that I
weigh in on it from a creative concept
but I'm also approving t-shirt designs
and banner designs and going through all
that stuff through all the different
departments and doing the approvals of
all that day-to-day process sounds like
quite a few hats it's it's a lot of hats
it's funny I used to marvel at Vince's
ability when I first started coming in
the office I've had a working kind of
behind-the-scenes relationship with
Vince since probably I started in the
Debbie w95 since like early 96 I just
was always fascinated with the behind
the scenes of the business and how it
actually all came together as much as I
was doing it in the ring and he and I
just kind of clicked in that sense and
we started working together and I didn't
meet staff his daughter until quite a
few years later and then we ended up
having a relationship and the whole
thing but I had this working
relationship with Vince and as time went
on and I got more and more involved in
that and then kind of later in my career
he kept always asking me like when are
you gonna stop messing around on the
ring and come do some real work in the
office you know you need to be in the
office and
to get you in the office and I used to
marvel at how many hats he wore and how
quickly he could change them you know
he'd be talking about a foreign tour and
box office receipts or or you know a
touring strategy or marketing strategy
for that and then two seconds later he's
looking at a t-shirt design and
approving colors and that and then that
would go away and now he's you know
looking at some new talent or he's like
this just with so many hats that he that
he wore and it used to amaze me at how
quickly he could change gears and I find
myself now having to do that same thing
and it's it's really cool to see
yourself growing that way cuz I used to
think how does he keep that all straight
and at first I couldn't keep it straight
and now you just you learn it you know
you you learn that you adapt to that
process I know we only have a few
minutes left I feel like I can ask you
questions for hours so maybe we'll do a
round two sometimes I love it this is
great
the I'd love to ask you some rapid-fire
questions yes and I think we could do an
entire session just on productivity but
just really quickly what is the the book
that you have gifted most to other
people or any book you've gifted a lot
to other people I don't know that I can
answer that question I don't get books
much my friends aren't big readers at
this we can come back to that what what
what band or song have you been playing
most on your iPhone or or in the car
otherwise um it's so lately it's it's
been anything heavy Metallica Motorhead
I'm you know I'm in like training mode
for Wrestlemania so I had 10 o'clock at
night I need to put something on the
stereo that just makes me gets me an
ass-kickin mode if you could only do one
or two physical exercises for the rest
of your life movements what would they
be Wow
I think if at this age if I could do
like freestanding just bodyweight squats
and like push
and kind of bodyweight exercises would
be where I'd be at because I think you
can stay in phenomenal shape doing them
and you don't need a whole lot of space
or equipment I should at some point
choose do to buddy of mine named Travis
Brewer who is a top competitor at
American Ninja Warrior and you guys
could could trade workouts I think
that'd be amazing
yeah easy that's awesome he's a little
monster I'd bet I what advice this will
be the last question before I ask you
where people can find out more about you
online but what advice would you give
your 20 year old self don't take it all
so serious you know and and and be more
open it's it's man when you're so
focused on making it and your I always
had fun in the business and it was one
of the things that I like I could like I
can look at it now and say like I didn't
take everything so seriously that it was
detrimental to me but like there were
times when it just something happened it
just eat me up you know what I mean and
I would be gone yes just couldn't take
it because I was so hungry to get to
that next place and the you need to keep
that that perspective of where
everything lays out you know there's
times when I when over the years when we
looked at each other and my friends
within the business little group of guys
and we'd always look at each other and
at a certain point in time you just
laugh and go like it's the phony fight
business or wrestle in our underwear you
know I mean I get all worked up about
and and I think that that is the biggest
thing is just not taking it so seriously
and then and then being open to stuff
you know it's it's funny I mentioned
that I listen to the Anthony Robbins
interview with you and I was fascinated
with it I met Anthony one time and it
was probably 2000 I was just kind of
like getting to a high spot in my career
and this happened to be in a hotel
I look over next to me he's checking and
Maximus it's just a big giant dude you
know and
I thought I recognized him from TV and
he looked over me said how you doing
that's great how are you good and he you
know I got my keys and I went getting me
elevator and he gets in the elevator
with me and he looked at me and said he
has forgive me I don't know I don't know
what you do but I clearly see people
looking at you and I clearly see or
somebody and I don't what what do you do
and I so I tell him who I am and what I
do and I said I've seen you on TV I'm
you know and um you know one of those
two second chance meetings in an
elevator right and this really impressed
me that I get back a couple weeks later
and I get a big box of like the cassette
and his books and all his stuff he had
written me this handwritten letter and
sent it didn't know how to get a hold of
me send it to the WWE office whatever
two weeks a month later when I come back
through the office at some point I'm in
my travels they give it to me and I'm
like wow this is amazing I was too young
and stupid and unopened at the time to
foster a relationship or I listen to the
tapes and I and I read the books and and
all that stuff and if I'd have thought
about it maybe I would have reached back
out to say thank you and like hey like
this is really cool could you know and
he invited me to one of his seminars and
and you know I was just at that time a
camp doing good like I don't you know it
was close to it I wish I was more open
to it I wish I could have had the
bandwidth to not be so absorbed in what
I was doing in my moments going for that
I could have said by this guy he could
teach me so much and that I should call
it and just you know foster that
relationship because he put them he put
the put the hand out and I was a guy you
know I don't even him you know and in it
those are things that I look at there's
other opportunities in my life that I
wish and I wish that was right in front
of me and I could have grabbed that but
I was too narrow-minded to see it you
know well this has been fascinating
you're fascinating guy I would love to
do round two sometime but we're at a
time I know your schedule is incredibly
impressive to me where can people find
more about you online say hi and so on
it's so Twitter what's my Twitter am was
a guy
it's a - at Triple H I don't know I just
know how to push the buttons on it if
you search that he's easy yeah Debbie
w.com is for our for our company and our
site and all that you know I do stuff on
Twitter and whether anybody believes or
not I actually do it it's not somebody
else doing it it's me so if it's
terrible it was me if it was really good
it was me you know that if you want to
go back and look at my career the WWE
Network is a great place to do it all
the historical content is on there you
know that's that's really me but you
know for me I'm uh you know you say I'm
fast and I'm fascinated by this process
and what you do and how you do it and
I'd love to do this again because I I
think these kind of things it's funny a
lot of things I said in here when you
ask me questions today like I'm I feel
like I gave you long-winded answers I
apologize if I did but like so I'm
almost explaining it to myself as you're
a smell like I never thought about it
that way so I'm kind of explaining it
you go like yeah that's really cool you
know not long-winded at all they were
your great storyteller you're a great
story creator an incredible performance
I hope I am I'll never be as big as you
but hopefully I will be as bulletproof
as you are when I'm 45 so until next
time thank you so much thank you very
much
this episode is brought to you by listen
headphones listen headphones are
gorgeous made out of real exotic
reclaimed wood but they are also doing
good in the world
proceeds from each purchase help someone
to hear for the first time through the
Starkey Hearing Foundation I've been
using listen headphones since they came
out partially because the founders
started the company after reading the
4-hour workweek and now they're
available at Nordstrom and all over the
place there's super high quality and if
you want to see the headphones that I
travel with that I love both in ear and
out of ear so kind of big all old-school
headphones then you can go to listen
headphones calm forward-slash Tim that's
LST n headphones calm forward slash Tim
you will also get a $50 that's right $50
discount that's a big whopping 5-0 folks
so go to listen headphones calm forward
slash Tim LS TN headphones calm forward
slash Tim this episode is brought to you
by 99designs which is your one-stop shop
for all things graphic design related
they have thousands upon thousands of
designers around the world you put up
what you want whether that's a business
card a t-shirt a website and app
thumbnail whatever and they submit
drafts mock-ups and designs that you can
choose from and you get an original
design you love or your money back I
have used them for years including to
grab cover concepts for the 4-hour body
which went on to become number one New
York Times and it really was a
springboard for everything so go to
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim and
you can also get two things a ninety
nine dollar upgrade and just for the
month of April just for you guys you can
get an additional $30 off and that is
total savings of 129
so check out 99designs com forward slash
Tim and until next time thank you for
listening
you